hold me close young tony downs
[Music]
courtney cox's all-star jam sesh was a
special gift to lisa kudrow
that was the most thrilling thing ever
on sunday courtney shared this epic
collaboration to instagram
which features her alongside ed sheeran
brandi carlyle
and elton john belting out to one of the
pop icons greatest hits
[Music]
and while the original song is titled
tiny dancer
the group was actually singing a version
inspired by the one and only
phoebe buffet no way the most romantic
song ever was the way we were
uh see i i think the one that elton john
wrote for um
that guy and who's the boss in this
classic moment from friends
phoebe is convinced the song is
referring to one of tv's most beloved
sitcom stars
what song is that pheebs um hold me
close young tony downs
and 25 years later fans received this
epic cover version which had a special
dedication at the top
lisa kudrow this is for you one two
three
[Music]
today
well lisa kudrow saw this amazing gift
and took to her instagram with her
heartfelt reaction
okay ed sheeran
courtney cox randy carlisle and elton
john
that was the most thrilling thing ever
it was so good but she did have one note
for the group
but technically it's um though
um hold me close young tony danza
so but you know that but what you did
was great too
you know and the including the song the
original song that you wrote cyril
that was really good
another important reaction followed
later that day
when tony danza himself shared
courtney's post to instagram
and wrote quote first the routine now
this
you've made my day once again i'm
honored
tony's message refers to a recent
courtney and ed collaboration where they
recreated another fan favorite moment
from the series
last week courtney posted this video to
instagram featuring her and the hit
singer doing the routine
a hilarious choreographed dance between
monica and ross on friends
[Applause]
leading up to the premiere of the hbo
max special friends the reunion
courtney's routine partner david
shrimmer told et about his
initial reaction to joining the cast i
remember being incredibly
impressed with the other five actors i
just thought this was the best
casting i had ever seen or been a part
of
and then over the 10 years obviously we
really grew close as a family and part
of the reason was that
that initial success of the show was
something that no other
no one else could relate to or or was
going through except the other five
actors so
we really we really got close because of
that experience too